Jetzt wird es buch hier roboter in meinem körper nano roboter
sollen das können forschungsteams arbeiten weltweit daran und die ersten prototypen sind tatsächlich vielversprechend
Ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht übrigens wie ihr zu whatsapp tom bender gar nicht da sei der fahrer
Am ende des videos und jetzt dazu alle wichtigen facts machen sie uns vielleicht bald schon unsterblich was können sie was
andere behandlungen nicht können jetzt in science fiction herzlich willkommen
Es klingt zunächst wie science fiction aber forschungsteams weltweit sind tatsächlich dran miniroboter die
selbstständig den körper checken medizin an die richtige stelle bringen patienten und patientinnen von innen wieder zusammenflicken
und große op s durchführen nano box könnten die zellen unseres immunsystems
anregen erreger zu bekämpfen oder gar
selbst krebszellen in den selbstmord treiben und in den letzten jahren ist viel passiert in diesem bereich viele fortschritte wurden gemacht die
anforderungen annahme bots sind groß zunächst einmal dürfen sie auf keinen fall in den kapillaren stecken bleiben also in den ganz engen
blutbahn besten sollen sie sogar so klein sein dass sie sich zwischen die zellen der kapillaren in das durchblutetes gewebe
Zwecken können und hier liegt das erste problem
Denn je kleiner das bauteil dafür ist die oberfläche wird im vergleich zum volumen immer größer bestimmte dinge wie kugellager
Die wir aus großen maschinen kennen sind sogar nicht mehr kontrollierbar beziehungsweise würden viel zu groß eine idee zur lösung dieses problems
Kommen von shawn das aus san francisco, er hat nano bots entwickelt die etwa
So groß sind wie ein bild auf einer festplatte also etwa 35 mal 35
Nanometer konkret handelt es sich um
hexagonalen röhren die nachrichten in ihrem inneren beherbergen und sie bestehen aus dna dem speichermedium
Des lebens wenn sie in kontakt mit dem richtigen zelltyp kommen geben sie ihre nachricht preis dazu, dass
Seit ein paar jahren kann man mit speziellen
computerprogramm dna ketten so aufbauen dass sie sich danach von ganz allein zu etlichen verschiedenen formen
zusammenfalten ich habe damit bisher bestimmt über 100 verschiedene strukturen erzeugt angelehnt sind diese name boards an die entdeckung einer
faltkunst namens dna origami
Im jahr 2006 diese technik hat sich auch ein
forschungsteam der arizona state university zunutze gemacht die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler haben nano bots auf dna basis entwickelt die
eigenständig krebstumore suchen und noch viel mehr in tierversuchen
attackierten die nano bot nicht nur mehr tumore und metastasen
Erfolgreich sondern schnitten ihnen auch noch wird thematisch die blutzufuhr ab konkret heftet sich ein adapter
des nano boards an ein tumor blutgefäß dass nanoröhrchen entfaltet sich und das eingelagerte thrombin wird frei
sorgt für blutgerinnung und der krebs tumor stirbt ab
zitat wir haben damit das erste autonome dna basierte roboter system für eine zielgerichtete
krebstherapie entwickelt diese technik kann gegen ganz unterschiedliche krebsarten eingesetzt werden da auch die blutgefäße die die krebszellen
Ernähren in allen fällen gleich aufgebaut sind das sagt einer der beteiligten forscher jahren aber es gibt weitere
Herausforderungen wie sollen angebots, im menschlichen körper gesteuert und angetrieben werden wie kann, man
Sie nach dem eingriff, am besten aus dem körper entfernen ein forschungsteam aus manchester hat ein
programmierbares molekulares pick up system entwickelt ein winziger roboterarm konstruiert auf biologischen makromolekülen
kann, gezielt einzelne moleküle aufnehmen kontrolliert bewegen und auch wieder absetzen
Diese drei schritte nehmen nur wenige sekunden in anspruch die erfolgsrate immerhin 80 prozent der name bot besitzt einen ph
sensitiven motor beziehungsweise rotor wird dass er durch die gezielte zugabe von säuren und basen
gesteuert werden kann dieses konzept will das forschungsteam jetzt auch auf andere verbindungen übertragen denn bislang ist es nur mit einer bestimmten moleküls
Möglich doch es gibt nicht nur nano boards auf dna basis ein forschungsteam aus manchester und hongkong hat jetzt vor kurzem bot aus
spirulina algen
Gebastelt ein entscheidender durchbruch die vorteile dieser bio it bots liegen auf der hand sie
Fluoreszieren und außen bestehen sie aus magnetischen eisenoxid so lassen sie sich jederzeit
im körper orten aufspüren und aktivieren denn sie sind quasi magnetisch und können sich so
fernsteuern lassen das forschungsteam beschreibt wie ihre bots arzneimittel freisetzen die krebszellen angreifen dazu einer der beteiligten forscher
costas
kostenlos die entwicklung von nano bot jeden körper angetrieben und gelenkt werden können war und ist ein heiliger gral in diesem bereich
dennoch ist auch klar dass hier noch einige arbeit
Notwendig ist um erste klinische studien durchzuführen
ein weiterer punkt an dem die forschung noch dürfte ist der preis der name boards zwar können auch schon derzeit ein paar milliarden dna name
produziert werden doch für versuche an größeren tieren oder auch menschen braucht man wohl 1000 bis
Millionenfach größere mengen, im großen und ganzen
Seht ihr also selbst nano bots haben tatsächlich ein
Riesenpotenzial der riesige vorteil solcher bots es gibt keine nebenwirkungen sie können absolut exakt konstruiert werden und arbeit. Genau da wo sie sollen schon heute
Arbeitet die medizin mit wirkstoffen medikamenten die so konstruiert sind dass sie nur da wirken
Wo sie sollen so ein inhalator der ist das beste beispiel feiner nebel bringt den wirkstoff nur dahin, wo er gebraucht wird
In die lunge nicht mehr der ganze körper wird geflutet es gibt viel weniger nebenwirkungen bei der lunge ist das relativ einfach
aber an anderen organen oder bei krebs oft nicht möglich hier können nano bot die lösung bringen und uns der
unsterblichkeit zumindest ein wenig näher bringen die vision wäre dass nahezu alle krankheiten die lokal auftreten und schwer zugänglich sind
gezielt bekämpft werden könnten krebs
chlamydien und vieles mehr
könnte wirklich
ausgerottet werden wahnsinn wenn er als erstes neues zum thema an bord so zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an
dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen von mir vom neuesten video vorab
garantiert ihr konto direkt in der redaktion von pixum mitmachen und mir themen vorschlagen oder mit abstimmungen
mitbestimmen der direkte draht zu mir einfach draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Glocke vergessen ja hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch. Draufklicken kunst organe aus dem 3d drucker kunst vagina
erfolgreich implantiert ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran